checking back in with chief
meteorologist ted florento he's got a
great shot to share with us
ted you haven't seen this yet i wanted
to show it to you right it's like this
is exciting okay so there's
this shot just as tower cam alone shows
resorts world all the big players
resorts world
and over here look at this msg sphere
all in one tower cam shot both under
construction
both near the station which means it
spells trouble for us because we're
going to be at both locations
quite a bit right encore wind
yes yes to our resorts world yeah this
is going to be great too so great to see
that tower cam shot of everything under
construction as we get
back to normal again current
temperatures outside so teddy hill 75
degrees right now and summerlin 67
72 for aliante 75 for downtown and north
las vegas mid 70s for the east side it's
just
perfect out there right 73 for seven
hills roads ransom mountains edge at 70
along with southern highlands and 73 for
henderson a lot of people asking me hey
are we going to warm things up and some
are asking hey let's stay in those 70s
because that's like perfect for some of
you 71 in prep
72 boulder city 79 for laughlin and 83
currently for death valley definitely
even comfortable
at this hour clear skies right now here
brian
with the other radar network doing their
sweeps around the region
you'll notice the echo zone up here into
utah and into lincoln county
white here indicates snowflakes coming
down look at that as you're starting to
head out
towards zion meanwhile we're dry here
all the way southward into southern
california this is all stemming from
that low
that's just been sitting around the
region now slowly moving its way to off
towards the east
the back side of that bring us those
northerly winds that we saw yesterday
and for the day today
it's also keeping us cooler than normal
now your wind for tonight not so bad
tomorrow for your friday looks pretty
good actually for your wins across the
region
staying mainly light but then saturday
unfortunately you'll see those winds
pick up again
for saturday and also sunday so here's
your drive and movie forecast tonight's
feature
alex backus to the future
is that all right they just said it was
a good one
in my ear but so i just we'll see what
alex is though
i don't know yeah i don't know alex
we'll see she's picked to be about my
stuff all right here's how it looks
outside for tonight 71 for 8 pm
9 pm 68 degrees 65 for 10 p.m
winds are staying light tonight all
right highs for tomorrow temperatures in
the mid to high 70s across the valley 75
for centennial hills 76 mountains so
basically we're still staying in those
70s
we're still staying at least near normal
rather than
shooting up back to the high 80s to 90s
that we've been seeing lately
74 for prompt boulder city 75 laughlin
at 86 degrees
alex backus to the future i like it i
thought it was good
all right temperatures before this week
high
70s don't get to those 80s till one day
look at that mid 80s
and we'll cool things off a little 90
degrees a week from tomorrow that's your
most accurate forecast back to you
thanks ted